[Music]
la la la you ready big guy
yeah I'm like totally ready everyone in
the city is a shot at being a storm in
our thinking competition this thanks is
about to explode with major piggy power
go home see you're really funny looking
that's alright cuz I get things cooking
come my lady come come my lady you're my
butterfly sugar oh my gosh look at her
butt oh my gosh look at her are you okay
oh yes I'm fine thank you how are you if
you want to become stars and win a
hundred grand and you better be ready to
work harder than you've ever worked in
your lives
oh yes that was very bad
we're strong there's no here where were
you I was a rehearsal but I don't want
to be in your gang I want to be a singer
lawyered up with a sunlight you music
you know some talk to you I can sing but
I get so scared come on
be confident don't you want this I'm
back what is going on here the moments
what if reason only squeeze it in Hobie
we completed these minute golden don't
let fear stop you from doing the thing
you love you know what's great about
hitting rock bottom there's only one way
left to go and that
[Music]
this my son
she's not even that good yeah totally
[Music]
just see
I'm sorry uh
[Applause]
why don't you rehearsing I'm through
they said I'm an intolerable egomaniac I
don't even know what that means and cue
the crazy old lizard
good morning mr. moon I got Judith from
the bank on line two actually a math
score back my